Bloomberg News national political
reporters to heal Kapoor joins us for a
look at the us-mexico tariff agreement
and other developments good morning good
morning so give us some sense of what
led to this agreement obviously there
was some Republican pressure from
lawmakers there on the president also
some reports about the economy that
weren't looking so good but what did
lead to this I think those two things
put a lot of pressure on the president
to come to a deal the economy would have
taken a major hit US consumers and
businesses would have ended up paying
more if these tariffs went into effect
and that would have deprived the
president of his best political weapon
heading into a reelection year if the
economy went south so I think there was
a lot of pressure on him to come to a
deal he didn't we he hasn't been leaning
on that good economy though right now
but it seemed to resonate regardless
well it certainly resonates with voters
I think voters cite the economy as a
single biggest right button I mean not
for him that he hasn't leaned on it at
this point right he's leaned heavily on
immigration and it remains to be seen
whether this is going to be a meaningful
shift in how mexico deals with migrants
and a meaningful change in migrants
coming up to the border or whether this
is more of a fig leaf for him to be able
to claim a victory clearly playing
hardball with mexico work could this
strategy work with china china is a much
tougher situation because his ask of
china is essentially restructuring its
economy about cracking down on things
like intellectual property theft
predatory practices that are essential
to china's economic model so the
prospect of tariffs about 25% of 300
billion dollars in chinese goods still
looms sadly the president returned home
after this five-day overseas trip to
another battle with nancy pelosi it's
looking increasingly difficult for her
to sort of hold the line on impeachment
inside her own party isn't it it is
there's a growing conviction among
progressives that the president has
committed impeachable offenses and that
the house should move to that to at
least open an inquiry about impeachment
if not moved to a vote but Nancy Pelosi
I think is playing this very very
cautiously she's reading the same polls
that we are that the public is not there
yet and she doesn't want to be seen as
overreaching to the detriment of her
vulnerable members and impeachment isn't
even the slam dunk within the Democratic
Party in the house is it it's not there
about there between 40 and 50 Democrats
who have come out for it in the house
they're probably more of them who
support it quietly but it's not clear
that there are 218 votes to get there at
this point any chance that we know when
Robert
or might testify there are conversations
happening among Democrats about that but
they are wary of getting into a process
fight about will he or won't he they
want to focus on the substance of the
report you'll want to focus on the
investigations going after the
president's tax returns going after his
financial records through through banks
and they're fighting these battles in
court at this point if we look ahead to
the 2020 election and it's certainly the
Democratic candidates out there an
interesting week for Joe Biden and that
was that reversal that he had on the
Hyde Amendment what can you say just
about the week he had and why we saw
that reversal it was certainly a tough
week for Joe Biden on two fronts the
first tough we got would say of his
campaign about six weeks in he released
a climate change plan earlier in the
week that ended up lifting passages from
other sources charges of plagiarism
followed that and his campaign said it
was inadvertent they corrected that
later in the week he had an abrupt
reversal on the Hyde Amendment which is
the 1960s 1976 provision routinely put
in appropriations bills that prevents
federal money on programs like Medicaid
from being used to cover abortions
there's been a major shift in the
Democratic Party in in the direction of
repealing that amendment and Joe Biden
came out in favor of repealing that
amendment after initially saying in the
week that he was for the Hyde Amendment
do you know why enormous amounts of
pressure from the reproductive rights
community from progressive activists to
turn the page on this they say it only
harms women without means women of color
poor women well see hill where we thank
you for all of the context you gave us
too right now